yeah no way hey guys it's Max Ben and V
and today we are going to see how good
the new s24 Ultra is and if it can
compete with the pixel 8 Pro and the 15
Pro Max yeah so max went out and took a
bunch of photos and we haven't seen
these yet we're going to be voting to
see which one we like the best so this
is a selfie in this series of photos we
have a lot of mixed lighting which makes
it really difficult oh man this one's
really tough I do like the detail of the
one in the center it it is a little bit
dark like under your eyes but I still
like it yeah yeah same here the
background blur is actually really nice
on this one yeah it does have some blur
yeah yeah this one is not blurred at all
kind of blue it is very blue yeah let's
see what that is you guys voted for the
pixel 8 pixel bro yeah it looks not like
a cell phone image compared to the other
two and here we have a zoom
shot oh by the way you guys can grab a
piece of paper and just uh follow along
with us and see who wins yeah it's
usually a lot of fun so what do you guys
think all of three of these have 5x
cameras now this is tough definitely not
the right it's so soft and blurry
there's a lot of noise here I'm kind of
gravitating towards the left for some
reason yeah the one on the right is
trash honestly super blurry but yeah
probably this one right here s24 and s24
Ultra looks good surprisingly the pixel
8 Pro has a 48 megapixel telephoto we
have a 50 and a 12 the iPhone some look
better and here we have a portrait shot
o okay well first of all I noticed this
one messed up the cut out his shoulder
here his hair right there it just so
distracting I don't like that I'm going
with the center it's either this picture
or this picture more Center yeah
s24 Ultra uh so the interesting thing is
the pixel will not let you take a
portrait with the 5x still yep where
Samsung now added it which is really
nice now now we have the sun came out
hitting the car here these are all so
close I like the center I feel like it
has more detail and overall it has more
sharpness in the wheels yeah I'll go for
the center pixel 8 guys what's going on
no love for iPhone I thought this was an
iPhone Channel guess it's doing better
and here we have this back lit bright
sky but it's also kind of Moody overcast
if I'm looking at both of these pictures
uh I would love to combine these two
like the face on here is much brighter
versus here but you got a blown out sky
in the center but you got more detail
here too even though this is blown out
I'd probably choose this one in reminds
me more of like a DSLR shot yeah
interesting I really don't like the one
on the right it's super flat and gray um
but I do think I'm going to choose the
one on the left I like overall
well-rounded I feel like the one in the
center is a little bit too dark on her
and her clothing and also the skies
visible here too so 15 for one for the
iPhone
and this is a shot of downtown that's
all I will say Center holy moly that
looks good instantly kills it you got
potato over here on the right not as
good over here where all the details are
just flat so one of these phones is 200
megapixel the other two are 48 and this
is in high reses mode okay am I are we
going to get tricked here pixel pixel 8
Pro what is going on here we have 200
megapixel but the HDR is not as good
when you want to capture all of details
what I noticed that's a good
point clear that is looks so amazing so
200 is trash compared to
48 it's a lot more processing that's
needed shees now we have this portrait
shot this is a
2X
interesting I do like the one on the
left it's it's a nice contrast there
it's not like super white over here I
like the one in the center I like how
the shadowing and the Highlight roll off
on his face looks very very natural his
hair and like the texture on the jacket
really crisp so we got a center and left
and this is so tough cuz we have
foreground background this is such a
hard shot to
take Samsung and iPhone and this was
some Turkish coffee I tried it for the
first time was it good yeah it was good
now I want smooth I like the center I
feel like the one on the left everything
just has a warm tint all over it
everything's warm I like the one on the
left all right s24 and pixel here hey
looks like you got to get a new foam
that's more and we have this tough lower
lighting portrait shot I was going to
say the left because I really like all
the fine hairs with the blur edging but
I don't like how everything has a really
warm tint including like her shirt
whereas the one in the middle the kind
of the blue hues come out of the shirt
as well and everything like is nicely
colored good detail too I like that I'll
go with the left just
because oh first iPhone finally I don't
know happened with the Samsung here it's
really off all right we have this
Cathedral cany that's easy immediately
the center Center yeah oh yeah yeah the
sunset glow like M s24 I don't know what
happened with the 15 Pro Max detail
doesn't look great and it's so flat it
did not look like that in real life
really bad and we have this 1X portrait
I don't like the one on the right
because it feels like it's way too cool
because you know it's Sunset but like
their skin tones are kind of bluish
these ones are so close I like the left
because their faces are better exposed I
think in they're yeah I'll choose the
center cuz the background is actually
more blurry s24 and 15 Pro Max iPhone
coming back have you guys agreed or only
once or twice we have in the beginning
yeah and now Ultra wide time I'm going
for the center I love the sky and just
the contrast yes this one's brighter but
overall the picture here looks just way
nicer yep me too so much more detail in
the center all the texture is
visible now we have all this fine detail
with the 5x cameras interesting anyway I
like the center like on the left image
this is all blown out all the details
gone all the texture super sharp yeah
that's a tough one but I would
definitely this one has a lot more
detail which is very interesting yeah I
like the one good oh what in the world I
actually forgot what this is 12
megapixel telephoto and it looks
probably deep Fusion now it's starting
to get a little darker this is a
portrait of these blocks for Spokane
I've got to say the one on the left I'm
seeing more detail and I like how like
the color yellow is popping out more
it's more vibrant you know yeah I like
the one on the left the colors are nicer
pixel pixel 8 Pro and that was the
Samsung what are we doing with iPhones
man here's another portrait in low
lighting all right so I don't like the
one on the left I like the center I like
how it's Moody got all the colors that
are really popping out yeah I like the
one on the right okay so we got a center
and right o s24 to me the s24 looks like
the one the only one that looks like a
DSLR shot in the scenario and we have a
regular photo here only the Samsung
actually has a dedicated 3x lens 3x I
like the one on the right it still has
that blur effect yeah it does have some
blurry yeah and it and it looks better
overall so two and I actually don't know
which which are which two of them are 3x
crop from the main cuz they have to and
one is the actual Optical that's true I
do like the one on the right I like how
it really separates him from the
background and that is the pixel somehow
no way so there's no real purpose to
have a 3X lens on there and we have this
last bit of light against the sky HDR
bro yeah what in the world happened here
yeah I mean if I just look at the face
itself the center I like the the best
yeah just look at Max and this shows me
how old I am in that picture no yeah the
center I do like that the best um
everything is yeah I'll have to agree it
just the
natural
pixel iPhone what the iPhone is able to
get some of that Sky the mo best but the
image looks like trash Apple you're
embarrassing us here and this is after
Sunset and we have some differences she
I mean it's the one on the right for me
easy it's the one that's the least
blue it's it's just a good picture yeah
pixel pixel pixel Lake it got the white
balance spot on AI you know and we have
this uh top lighting that was nice and
warm looked cool I like the left I'm
just looking like at this tree and I'm
seeing all these fine details that I'm
not seeing in the other ones so even
though it's blue I still go with this
one the iPhone okay we have this far
distance um restaurant out there with
the lights and the buildings I choose
the one on the left like the first thing
I saw was how sharp it is the colors
yeah these look really flat and and blue
this one especially looks quite terrible
but I'm looking at these squiggly lines
these lights super sharp
S4 it's going to be a close one and we
got a really tough portrait I was
surprised how well all of them did dang
look at that it completely blew it out
oh dang it why'd you mention that I'm
guessing I love this one right here that
does look cool I don't like The Fringe
effect of How It's almost like double
blurry vision on some of these I'm going
to go with the center because I really
like the black contrast pixel and the
Samsung mess up I don't know but also we
have all this blown out I thought this
was I turned it into like bokeh and this
is a 2X portrait all of them will have
that mode oh I saw a difference I like
the one on the right look at her jacket
yeah I like the one on the right just
yeah me too I do like how the blacks
actually look black properly and
everything else and it's the most true
to life and that one is pixel pixel
Google is doing a great job they really
stepped it up last couple years we got
this sunset or past Sunset Carousel shot
if I were to keep a photo in my phone
I'd probably go with the one here on the
left it just the contrast is kind of
nice it's you know pink and purple over
here with the blue sky and the water
versus here it's like white blown out I
actually like the one in the center I
like how it's more white has less blue I
really don't like blue pixel and pixel
was it more like that Max yeah in
reality it looked very close pixel and
this
is potato yeah this is a portrait shot
at night uh with the 5x lens which one
was taken with the potato are you
tricking us bro no the left one for me
has the most detail dude same like it
you can see her face see her face
yeah 24 and I say the iPhone looks the
worst oh man what happened not Doo well
at all we got the trash goat from
Spokane I like the one on the left look
what happened there what is that wait a
that's some good processing dang yeah
the one on the left if you look really
closely you can see all these little
weld marks really cool oh you were right
the iPhone won that one so I have a good
amount of 5x because now they all have
5x lenses yeah I definitely like the one
in the center even though the clock is
sharper but you can actually see the
detail here actually see the bricks yeah
you can see the bricks right the lights
here nice color reproduction I like that
a lot so you guys are voting for Center
oh yeah which phone do you think that is
oh man the s24 iPhone yeah no
way and we got a I believe a 2X portrait
here I like the one in the center okay
you got it it just looks better yeah
okay so one thing you see right here you
see blown out looking in the center this
is the only one that has the red neon
and whatever that sign is comes out and
these lights are actually warm and you
have the dynamic range there it did a
great
job pixel it looks so good now we got a
Ultra wide Mac Daddy's yeah this is a
nice contrasty scene I'm pretty sure
that was not white yeah the center one
kind of lost the dramatic effect that we
had in real life I would go with the one
on the left just look at the first sign
how the light shines down on it it looks
natural yep me too I really love the
Moody feel of how dark it is but all the
colors pop here all the
glow that's how it looked like in real
life 15 Pro Max the
iPhone didn't do as well in this one
maybe the ultra rde and we have a
regular nighttime shot I like the center
his coat is nice and black without all
this gray noise and back here all of
this stuff looks good that's an
interesting one cuz his coat is
completely too dark here you can't even
see a zipper even though on this one you
can in general I'd probably go with the
one on the center yeah I don't know what
this one did it makes it tries to make
it look like daylight or obviously it's
not so the center is the 15 Pro oh wow
it's catching up it's catching up at
night huh surprisingly at night okay we
got this shot um I believe these are all
5xs I like the one on the right look at
that horse you can actually there's some
contrast there yeah I don't like here
where there's just basically a warm
filter over everything and then the
center one looks really overprocessed so
what do you think the right one is
iPhone how do they keep flipping like
this where like one will be perfectly
exposed true to life then it'll switch
to another phone another time and we got
the Lego sign my kids are so excited but
it was closed I don't
know what is this that's the wall man
well why are these dark it did the best
job maybe because it was really dark
outside that one's too Blue to White
perfect yep I mean this one looks like
you just got this from like Google
Images is it's just perfect all right
we're going to the left s24 W I don't
know why the pixel's trying to make
nighttime be day in a lot of these
really dark shots and we got this
beautiful reflection ooh in the water
yeah I would still choose the one on the
right even though I don't like the sky
this looks sharper it pops yeah it it
just pops right away yeah I'd agree I
don't like how gray and flat this is
that one looks really nice and mov yeah
even see in the water you have like pop
there where this is just all brought
together yeah soft Pro Max it's going to
be close this was heck a dark regular 2x
shot I like the one on the right you can
see his jacket clearly and I'm pretty
sure it's not green jacket it's a brown
jacket I like the center I was going to
say the left but it looks like
something's going on with the Shadows
where it messes up like kind of more
natural looking then look how clear his
jacket is right there it's not blurry I
know just out it looks the color so off
this is why I want to hear your guys'
opinions in the comments as well m and
there we go iPhone no love for Samsung
on this one this is close we're almost
done here we have an ultra wide at night
it was very dark I like the one on the
right just cuz it actually kept the red
color yeah I'd agree I don't like how
this one looks all too warm I iPhone oh
snap did a good job
wow we know what this is I had to take
another shot Samsung was in some
controversy for it 10x lenses now they
got 5x oh man it still took a picture
actually looks worse than last year so
they got it from Google Images uh maybe
but it looks worse than before we got
that and we got this with this phone I
you sure that's not a
flashlight I took like 10 shots this one
was one this one has either one or two
to make sure it's focused this I took
like 10 that is the best one I got dang
but all of them are 5x Optical okay we
obviously know it's the center but if I
were to actually guess which one's which
so the s24 the pixel and that's the
iPhone and you are exactly correct on
this one this looks like what a 5x
probably should do iPhone just can't
even focus no matter what I tried and
the Samsung is probably AI stuff there
doing copy paste from Google all right
guys so that is it for us voting if you
guys followed along please count up and
comment down below what your choices
were or if some phone really surprised
you or something stood out comment down
below these guys are telling up their
votes all right Ben what were your
numbers so I got 13 for the iPhone even
though in the beginning it was
smoked I for a while for like the first
seven pictures and it caught up which is
super crazy then 11 for the s24 and 11
for the pixel wow I got the same scores
as him but actually for a different
phone I got 11 for the s24 ultra 11 for
the iPhone and 13 for the pixel wow wow
so that was close there's definitely you
know there's preferences that go along
with it which is why we do it this way
and looks like the iPhone at the end
started to catch up quite a bit so you
take a lot of nighttime photos the
iPhone starts to excel but with that
said in the daytime these other two
phones are doing a really good job so
thank you guys for watching go ahead and
click that Circle above to to subscribe
check out one of those great videos
right over there and we will see you in
the next
[Music]
one